hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast introduction to labcoat
live smart start training courses for XP
protein expression systems presented by
Stephanie Culbertson a technical
training specialist at Thermo Fisher
Scientific I'm dr. CV Valdez of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots sponsored by
thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information about our sponsor visit @ww
thermo Fisher comm before we begin I'd
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen type the
questions into the drop-down box that
appear on the screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please use the ask a
question box and let us know you're
having a problem please join me now in
welcoming Stephanie Culbertson our
presenter I will now turn the
presentation over to her welcome
Stephanie thanks so much Susie
appreciate it and hello everyone thanks
for joining the session today so my
presentations may be a little bit
different than some of the other ones
that you've been watching today I'm
going to talk not a technical
presentation but actually talk to you
about training support that thermo
Fisher can potentially provide to you or
someone you know to help you get started
with the X using the X P protein
expression system many people may not be
aware that thermo Fisher's life science
group offers education services for our
customers or you may know of some things
we offer but not others for quite some
time we have offered training related to
things like our applied Biosystems
instruments if you buy a qPCR sequencing
machine one of our field application
scientists will come out to your lab to
help you get started using it but in the
past few years we have expanded our our
goals with training and we want to cover
broader workflows and more applications
that we can help you with so one of the
areas that we have
landed two and it's just this past year
is protein expression and helping people
get started using the X P protein
expression systems the éxito xB 293 and
the brand-new xB SS insect expression
system that just launched a few weeks
ago so if that sounds like you the
training may be helpful and I'm going to
go tell you a little bit about what we
offer here besides just trying to expand
the application technical areas that we
cover in our training from thermo Fisher
we've also been trying to think about
different ways that we could provide
training and help more people with
education on the products that they're
using so of course that we have added a
few more classes that our field
application scientists can offer at your
lab we do have several courses that you
can take coming in to training center
labs that we have at some of our thermo
Fisher sites where we'll be hands-on
training in a lab with you and classroom
training but but as I said where we've
been looking at ways we want to reach
out to even more people and so we we
have this new offering that we're
calling lab coat live which is an online
training it's more than just your basic
webinar so I'll begin the talk telling
you a little bit about what lab coat
live is and how it differs from other
online training you might be familiar
with and then I'll tell you a little go
into a little bit of detail on what we
actually cover in our protein expression
courses covering XP 0 XP 293 and x BSS
so what is lab coat live so the idea
behind the training for us was really to
try to replicate the experience that you
would have if you came to one of our
training or customer experience center
labs where we'd be doing classroom and
hands-on lab work together in our labs
but set up that same type of training
from the convenience of your own lab so
what we'll do is actually send you
reagents send you a kit and and some
specific protocols that we want you to
use to do experiment with that kit and
then we'll kind of do a virtual version
of those classroom and lab interactions
so we'll have interactive online
lectures again it's not a big webinar
where there's hundreds of anonymous
people it's interactive they're small
classes we right now limit to maximum of
10 people and we encourage you to
participate you can talk to your
instructors you can ask them questions
you can share data with them to get
feedback on how your experiment is going
so far so it's really as close as we can
replicate to what you would get with an
in-person training and of course you are
we're following up lectures with your
actual hands-on experiment that you'll
be doing in your lab but to support you
since your trainer is not there with you
there's actually a class dedicated class
website that you can go to that has
copies of those lab protocols the slide
deck handouts to refer back from the
lectures and also whenever possible we
provide videos showing someone showing
the instructor doing the techniques in
the lab and showing particular steps in
the workflow that are really important
to do the technique correctly so you can
see it there so it's almost like having
somebody there with you will recreate it
as best we can and then of course we'll
follow up after each major step of the
experiment with another interactive
session where you can share your data
your instructor will actually look at it
with you and talk about what happened
how it went and any tips that can help
you improve in the future in the case of
the XP system as well these are more
complex workflows as you all know they
take multiple weeks so we actually start
this process again we go through this
cycle multiple times we will have a
follow-up to go over results together
and then we'll have a lecture going over
the next step in the workflow that
you're going to do in the lab
you go and do those steps and then we
meet again to go over your results and
and then at the end have a final review
of everything that you did there so we
do our best to recreate what you would
get to different instructor actually was
there with you
out of this work so the online lectures
are provided through a system called go
to training it's somewhat similar to
what we're using today for this
broadcast or if you've used something
like WebEx or or Live Meeting but to go
to training have some nice interactive
tools so definitely allows audio you'll
be you'll either be there you can speak
to your instructor if you want to or you
can also use a chat box to interact
during the sessions we have even drawing
controls where you could we can give you
control to highlight things on a screen
if we're trying to point something out
an image for example and there's
reference files you can download
directly during that lecture so lots of
tools to that you can interact with your
instructor as they're presenting
mentioned that class dedicated class
website that you can go to to get all
your information so these websites are
actually hosted on the thermo Fisher
cloud if you go to our website thermo
Fisher comm and click on the cloud icon
we've got multiple applications there
various things that can help support you
in your research and one of them is that
now an app called education Connect
which is where all of these class
websites are hosted
the class websites look something like
this so it's a dedicated page for each
class and each session of the class not
even to the course in general again it's
not these are all resources copies of
the slide decks those videos I mentioned
that will help you with techniques all
of this is accessible from this page and
another feature on this page that I
didn't mention earlier is a dedicated
discussion forum for the class so you
can post any questions you have or
updates for your instructors on your
experiment and how things are going
whenever you post to this discussion
forum the instructors will automatically
get an email informing them that that
you have posted a message and they will
get back to you quickly perhaps not
immediately
everybody's gonna be working on
different things in between the online
sessions but they will get back to you
probably within a few hours and and this
is really your dedicated kind of
technical support forum for the few
weeks that you're in our class so it's a
nice resource to have there
before I get into the specifics of the
XP expression classes I thought I'd
pause for a moment Susie do we have any
questions so far about how lab cut web
works in general we don't have any
questions quite yet but I know our live
audience will bring us some for the end
sounds good
great let's move on then talk about the
specific classes that we offer for
protein expression and there are classes
for other application areas I should
mention but of course we for expression
world we definitely want to focus on
these so the main ones that you all
might be interested in so again we offer
these classes that we call smart start
with a goal to help anyone who's new to
the systems getting started or maybe if
you already worked with the systems a
bit but you feel like you could optimize
your results a little bit more we'll
help you get started with the system
this smart start training the courses
for XP Cho and XV 293 are quite similar
in both cases the courses run about four
weeks it's actually four weeks plus one
day for a final session at the end
in both cases we'll send you the main
expression system kit or the starter kit
that we have establish those systems
either xv2 or XP to 93 that has all the
key reagents that are specific to these
workflows we will ask you to provide
some equipment we can't provide
everything that you need to do sessions
so we will of course assume that you
have a basic cell culture lab setup that
you have your incubator and your shaker
all ready to go and we do actually ask
that you provide a few of the
consumables specific to this workflow so
things like flasks or you know pipettes
things like that we do have a checklist
of what those things are that you need
to have on hand before the class starts
and we will send that to you before you
get started of course for the online
sessions too you'll need a computer with
internet access
there aren't any official prerequisites
for the class but just to give you a
little bit of knowledge
these are definitely introductory
classes with regard to be specific
products and this specific application
but these are probably overall maybe
intermediate level classes we do assume
that people joining this have at least
some background knowledge of basic cell
culture techniques and basic molecular
biology techniques like cloning
cover them very briefly in the class but
our main focus in these courses is
really about the things involved in the
system kits the cell culture and the
transfection steps that are the most
important for the protein production
process so so just want to set some
expectations there that we do assume a
little bit of background knowledge
coming into this but but somebody who is
at least have some knowledge of protein
expression would do find coming in here
even if they haven't done it before the
X BSF system class is a little bit
longer than the other two most of the
other aspects are the same again we're
going to provide you with the system kit
that's the basic starter reagents for
the system same equipment required and
the same prerequisite requirements as
the other courses
the main difference and the reason why
this class is a little bit longer is
just that the X BSS system is a
baculovirus based expression system and
so you need illuminate a little bit
longer to add those steps to make virus
before and do infection as well as doing
transaction and the other things that
are involved so a little bit more
complex workflow and we want to spend a
little more time with you in both of
these cases - you'll note um you know if
you're really working on your own
working with these products would
actually probably go a little bit faster
so we've added a little bit of time if
some of the key workflow steps to make
sure that that you know something goes
wrong you have some time to do another
run of the you know get another cell
culture started or do another run of the
experiment so we try to build in a
little bit of buffer time in case in
case you need a little extra time to
redo one of the one of the key steps
the learning objectives for all the
courses are pretty similar so again I
think I mentioned our target audience
for these classes are really scientists
with some background experience and
maybe you've done ecoli expression but
you're new to doing insect or mammalian
expression so anybody who's getting
started with these kids or maybe you've
tried it once before and and and you
need some help optimizing our goal with
this just to help you so we'll
definitely be outlining the workflow and
and highlighting for you what we think
are the most critical steps that you
need to pay the most attention to will
make sure you understand all the
components of the kit especially the
ones that are unique to the system like
the enhancers and feeds for the protein
expression process and why why they're
in there and how they're going to help
you to use them and we'll really go over
the fundamentals of the other steps that
you're more familiar with but but some
of the things that people kind of take
for granted for instance you know a lot
of people focus on the cloning and the
transparent they kind of take for
granted the cell health and so we'll
really focus on on how to properly
subculture and keep yourself as healthy
as possible as a really key part of the
workflow for the X PSS system we will
also of course cover on how to make the
back med and how to efficiently produce
baculovirus to do cell infection and
we'll go over the proper protein harvest
in all cases and at the end we we hope
that you'll leave knowing again those
key steps throughout the workflow and
have a good idea of which steps you can
optimize to most improve your your
protein yield
but for the XP Cho and XP 293 courses
here's a little bit more information
about how those courses actually look so
and during those four weeks there's
actually four of those interactive
online sessions we've broken down the
workflow high-level basically into
buying and sub culturing yourself doing
the transfection
and and adding the enhancers and then
actually harvesting your protein and
detecting and quantifying your yield so
to support those major steps and we'll
start with the online session just over
viewing the kits and the components and
really focusing on the details of the
thaw and subculture and then that you'll
will be for you to go into the lab and
actually perform the subculture and have
the cells go through a couple of
passages then we'll meet again to
discuss transfection right before you
yourself should be ready to do the
transaction in the lab and then right
after the class you'd go do the
transaction in the lab fully and then
same thing as your cells are producing
their protein during the protein
expression period we'll meet again just
a few days before your harvest go over
concepts that should help you and
harvest and then have you go do that and
then at the end we'll have a final
summary a final review go over the
results that you've seen any questions
that you have on on things that you saw
and any tips we have to optimize for the
future the four sessions are each 60 to
90 minutes the first two sessions are a
little bit longer you can imagine in the
first session not only are we covering
the technical aspects but also want to
set expectations for the class tell you
how lab coat live is going to work what
the schedule is like for the class make
sure everybody knows when the next
online session is things like that so
that session and the transaction are a
little bit longer and the last two
sessions are usually about an hour
those four sessions are delivered as I
mentioned earlier over four weeks plus
one day so this is kind of how it breaks
down so have the initial session and
then you have about two weeks for your
hands on time of thawing and sub
culturing yourselves we'll be checking
in with you online and the discussion
forum to see how things are going in
those in-between periods and then again
well we'll have a full online
interactive lecture and discussion
session right before your cells should
be ready to do the transaction step then
have you do the transaction and meet
again right before protein harvest and
then have that final results in review
once you should have had time to do your
protein analysis and see how things went
any questions so far on these classes
there are no questions so far
right let's look at the XPS F which is
quite similar but as I mentioned it's a
little bit more complex workflow since
in addition to all those steps of
working with the cells and your optimal
protein yields we also have to make a
virus make a vacuole a virus stock so
takes a little more time and we do have
one extra online session for for that
class so adding on to the kind of
workflow breakdown before in addition to
the sub culturing and saw of your cells
in the first session we'll also be
talking about doing the transformation
and and isolation of your back made and
how to screen for for good back made
clones the next session we'll discuss
you know how to actually transfer the
back mid and how you're going to harvest
and tighter your baculovirus stock then
the third session we'll talk about
actually doing the infection of the
cells with that baculovirus stock and
then the last two sessions are very
similar to the ones for xB Cho and xB
293 we're where we'll talk about just
your protein harvest and and tips for
for efficient harvest and detection and
also go over that final review and
optimization tips and again each of the
sessions of each of these sessions is
between 60 and 90 minutes depending on
the subject the earlier ones being
usually being the longer one but our
goal is definitely to make sure that
everyone again can be interactive and
ask the questions and that we can help
each individual as much as possible
here's that that calendar breakdown of
how those sessions are going to look so
a little bit longer everything stretched
out like I mentioned we had a little bit
of buffer time where we can because we
want to make sure that plenty of time to
do the analysis and production that you
need and maybe even a little extra time
in case you need to repeat some things
so in the case for this class those we
give you about two weeks a little bit
over two weeks to get that not only get
yourselves your xB SS nine cells thawed
but also produce your back mid and maybe
even repeat a transformation and
screening of back Matt if you need to
just in case then another two weeks to
complete your transection and harvest
your baculovirus and do the proper
tidying that we recommend to really get
the best possible results but once
you've got your good baculovirus doc
then the actual protein production goes
very quickly and and you'll only takes a
few days to produce protein harvest and
finish up with our last online lessons
but package within six weeks there
that's really it high-level but to the
hopefully that helps you know if these
classes might apply to you or someone
that you know that's going to be working
with these systems or might need some
help so if you're interested in
get back here so if you're interested in
the classes this is the webpage that you
can go to to get more information it's
thermo Fisher comm slash labcoat lives
when you get to this page there's a
links for each of the classes to another
page that has a lot more detail on
similar things that I discovered what's
what's involved in each class what's
covered who comes with it you can also
the pricing for each class is on this
page and you can also see the dates that
upcoming courses are offered and then
you can submit a registration and and
we'll get back to you on class
availability and all of all of those
things if you have any questions I
apologize that I didn't put it on this
slide but we have an email address that
is listed on this labcoat live page it's
just lab coat wise at thermo Fisher comm
you're welcome to send us questions
anytime as well
Thank You Stephanie for the
informative presentation and we will now
start that live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appear on the screen
and click that send button will answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's take a look at our incoming
questions and we do have a few already
coming in the first one is what is the
cost of the classes
so the actual cost it does vary by class
so I won't spend time loosing it out
here but let me take us back to that
slide with that that website that you
can go to so all the class prices are
listed at thermo Fisher comm slash lab
coat live the pricing varies by course
based on factors like the relative cost
of the reagent kits that were sending
you and the number of hours of online
training and consulting time that you'll
have with instructors one thing that's
not listed on this page and again I'm
sorry I didn't put it on a slide and
think of it ahead of time but another
site that you might want to go to we do
actually offer some discounts like group
discounts if maybe multiple people from
your lab might want to take the class or
if you sign up for multiple courses or
refer someone else to one of our courses
for that there's another website you can
go to and I'll try to say it slowly so
you could maybe write it down
it's learn thermo Fisher comm slash
promos cro MOS isn't promotions and at
that site again learner mo fisher comm
slash promos you can find out more about
those group discounts potentially that
might help some people
Thank You Stephanie and is there any
training on RNA sequence for lab coat
live specifically there's only one class
that we're offering on sequencing and
that one's related to analyzing sequence
of cells but that's all on that lab coat
live page I we do have other sequencing
instruction available I don't think we
have a specific kind of scripted class
on RNA seek but we definitely have field
application scientists that can help
with RNA seek but if you're interested
in training on that I encourage you to
contact another email address and again
I'll try to say it solely but it should
be pretty easy it's customer training at
thermo Fisher comm we reach out there
with your interest in RNA seek training
we can we can confer with our field
application scientists in that area and
see what they can provide for you
Thank You Stephanie and thank you to our
live audience we have some great
questions coming in now what would
happen if I have a problem with my
experiment and fall behind the class
schedule
very good question now that's something
I'm sure people might be concerned about
but as I did mention we did try to build
in some buffer time so that some steps
could be repeated where we know things
like maybe you saw yourselves and and
they don't seem to recovering well we
did build in a little bit of time where
you really could thaw some more cells
but if we do run into a worst-case
scenario where something something bad
happens and we really can't recover for
it
we'll definitely work with you on the
best resolution we can't fully refund
the classes once we send you the kits a
lot of the pricing of the classes is
based on the reagent kit that we are
sending you but we can definitely
reschedule you to another session or
we'll find alternate solutions we
generally have recordings available of
the online sessions that we have and
then we can provide those to you thank
you Stephanie and our audience members
want to know what if I have to miss one
of the online sessions if I accidentally
already answered that question so if I
just mentioned that we generally do try
to record the sessions for that exact
case in case someone is unable to miss
the cap class or unable to get to that
online session or you know if we haven't
recorded that exact session we usually
have previous recordings of the same
class and you can just contact us and
again that general email address that
you can send questions to is labcoat
live at thermo Fisher comm if that
happens during your class then one of
our class coordinators or the
instructors will make sure that you get
access to the proper recording
Thank You Stephanie and who are the
instructors it's actually a two-part
question who are the instructors and do
they work in research and development
so our instructors are all very
experienced scientists who have worked
on various applications similar to this
most of them actually work now in our
support functions so they're either
field application scientists or
technical support scientists who spend
their time answering questions on these
products every single day for people
that are out there using them every once
awhile rnd scientists will be a trainer
for us but most of the time you know
their their primary work has to be in
the lab but they are definitely involved
in the creation of all of our course
content so they are involved at least
indirectly and the support scientists
who are trainers are very experienced
scientists and and are able to give you
a lot of tips that will help you
Thank You Stephanie and I want to remind
our audience that any question is not
answered today will be answered via
email Stephanie would you like to
provide our audience members with a
closing remark before we head out today
not much new to say just definitely
again our our main goal is is wanting to
support people and help them be
successful
hopefully the very first time that they
use these products that they're just
getting started using them or help
people to be successful that's our main
goal in general and technical support
and across there Moe Fisher we want we
want your research to be successful and
that and that is makes us successful too
so so yep this is just one more way a
little even more proactive than just
troubleshooting questions where we can
hopefully help you before you even run
into any issues so definitely encourage
you to sign up if you're thinking about
it and we'd love to see you in the
classes
thank you again Stephanie and I also
want to thank Thermo Fisher Scientific
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to remind
everyone that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May of 2019 please share that with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and thank
you for joining us we hope to see you
again soon bye bye